you
um oh yeah my name is Cory and I've got
interest in this talk I was building
that the note app and trying to use
notes build an HTTP server I was having
a post to forum I made some HTML the
mid-post a form back to the server and
something was causing it not to work
like I couldn't get my data back on the
server side and so yeah like any like
many typical arrogant developers my
first instinct was not that there is any
problem with my code I assumed that
nodes built an HTTP server had a fog and
so I started it led me down a big rabbit
hole of them debugging HTTP and looking
at headers and requests and reading the
Specht and stuff like that night I
learned a lot of interesting stuff along
the way and so I've inspired me to share
with all of you so along with Matt who's
over there I have a consultancy that we
focus on number Jas and I called 201
created a member and usually that falls
pretty flat but like I think this
hugging cool so yeah so why lie quite so
actually this talk is actually about
literally riding HTTP requests and
responses by hand and you might ask why
you would do that which is a good
question but the HTTP is such a popular
successful protocol and we use it every
day through all of our different devices
are like browsers use it for us re
iphone apps with our API is use it for
us and stuff like that that all of our
experiences with HTTP are mediated
through these other tools and devices
and so I think it's actually very
interesting and sort of enlightening and
gratifying to actually like get down
into it's one of those sort of things or
I think we all know roughly what it does
and maybe some too much more detail than
others but there's nothing like actually
sort of like experiencing it to like
ground a theoretical or sort of like
other understanding of it
the real world so that's sort of the
general motivation and along the way
I'll talk about a few of the things that
we do now in our apps that are misuses
of HTTP and sort of like why motivate
why we do them and then also hopefully
if there's something I will talk a
little bit HTTP to and how it is
changing those practices and how it's
going to fix a lot of problems that we
have with HTTP one cool so this demo is
going to grab some HTML from google the
most basic way to get HTML the the way
the tim berners-lee did it back in the
day is just to type your request that
enter and you get a bunch of iht HTML
and back from a server so that is 0.9
this is sort of the way it was done
originally there wasn't much no one knew
where HTTP was going to go and so there
was no need for anything more there was
no concept of headers or anything like
that just get post actually knows other
verbs were there we definitely get and
then the URL and you got back response
immediately when you send a line feed
cool so with that other way we'll get to
HTTP 1.0 so now we've got a little bit
more we've got a version number in our
request for Matt and you'll notice this
time when I hid under nothing happens
this is because the server thinks it
might be some headers coming this case
I'm not going to give it any as soon as
i hit enter I get back my HTML so
forward this is a little snippet from
the HTTP won't point us effect
technically the spectral HTTP 1.1 OTT a
true respect it was created after HTTP
have been used a bunch in the wild and
some more documenting actually how it
was used so it's it's technically an
informational RFC and not a true spec
but anyway it acts like a spec it looks
like a spec and it's got a lot of things
like this has anyone ever read the one
point / won't go inspect serious
okay good yeah all right then okay so
hopefully there will be some stuff for
you to learn here um this is just this
is a sent this is like a grammar it's
described in the spec and it's
essentially like a rudimentary
programming language on your left you've
got your variable as a request on the
right you have the grammar that
describes how to create that the stuff
that begins with the asterisk is
optional and so we'll sort of like
ignore that for now but essentially you
got your request line headers a blank
line and then the message body if you
have any message body to descent this is
your request so you're sending it to the
server and then if you look in
furtherance back it actually defines
exactly what request line name so it
means this method SP request-uri ASP
HTTP version CR LF crl f is return
carriage return line feed and SP is just
a space so this becomes your method
request URI and then the version that's
HTTP won't find out and that's what it
looks like server okay so quickly and
this trying anyone know this triangle is
curiosity yeah this triangle is
responsible for the number one thing
that we always have to keep in mind when
making web apps which is limit our
number of requests this is the three-way
handshake and TCP client has to send a
packet to the server the server episode
pests and back a packet before you can
even start sending out your request to
the HTTP server this happens on every
single request that you make and it is a
non-negligible round trip this is why we
want to use like see the ends that have
edge nodes because we're actually
limited here by um by the speed of light
fiber-optic cables or latency as our
problem not bandwidth on the round trip
and so the amount of time it takes for a
packet to travel even like across the
country is actually not negligible and
if you're doing that two times for every
request that you make it does start data
so the white one of the ways we avoid
that latency is spreadsheets
right another one would be concatenated
files like the dog this is all about
minimizing request sense because HTTP
runs on TCP as also because in HTTP 1.0
every request sorry every connection
only gets you one response or put it put
the pretty other way one response per
connection so in the HTTP spec it
actually says that the connection has to
be closed by the server after sending
the response if you if you try this at
home you'll see when you get at at
Google when you get / HTTP one point out
it immediately closes the connection on
you I look something like that so in
HTTP 1.1 they tried to improve the spec
by saying this service should maintain a
persistent connection and so that one
number three here um it's to be 1.1 spec
it's mostly the same this one point oh
I'm leaving out a few headers but you'll
watch it soon as i hit enter I get my HT
to HTML and I still have the requested
open I saw the connection up and rather
to the server so I could get you know
the follow up here you know the take on
and it will send that back to me is a
not a ski but um so that's a change that
HTTP 1.1 made because they started to
realize how people who are using the
protocol and they tried to make it
better okay so another thing that we
given HTTP 1.1 is pipelining which is
where you can actually request multiple
assets from a server before you have
received any responses for them and I
have a demo of that also so this time I
have a local server
left side
so if I this server is a program to
return wait the number of milliseconds
that I have on this request oh that one
is going to take five seconds to come
back and we should good response about
seconds there we go and you'll see that
if I send one and then another one right
away both of them are going to go
through oh I'm sorry you start okay
oh and I'm right I'm running the
protocol wrong so I have to have a blank
line after each one so it knows that
it's done it thought the second line was
a header there okay so here we go have
two requests at once and you saw the
server gets them both before it sends
back the first one that's pipelining
pipelining was added page to be 1.1 to
help for the same reason that the
connection reuse but in practice it
doesn't work particularly well and it is
victim to something called head of line
blocking which is where if you've got a
really long response we just saw if
you've got a really long response you
have to wait the server has must return
the responses in the order that the
requests were received so if you have
asked for something that takes like 30
seconds to generate and then you ask for
five more things on the same connection
you won't get any of them until at least
30 seconds later so pipelining as useful
as it is is not particularly helpful and
as such it's actually not used all that
often there is something else that we do
instead which is called asset host
charting you can see here this is the
Wall Street Journal we've got a bunch of
different asset hosts they're all this
is our elder static a suppose wsj net
and then with different domains
different subdomains at the front and
this allows the browser is going to put
a bunch of different connection stall
sorry one connection per each of these
domains but effects will be now you've
got multiple requests in parallel going
to the same server if all these domains
go back to the same server the facet hoe
starting and because of the issues with
pipelining and other difficulties with
connections that's sort of why we use
that HTTP ok so now I'll flip it a
little bit and up now we've been using
typing our HTTP requests by hand to
request information the HTTP 1.1 spec is
actually pretty simple on the other side
the server slide this is the verbatim
from the spec it tells us that our
response consists of a status line some
headers and then a message body
and the status line looks like this
which translates to oops I want to pass
it my favorite says good um and then we
have to give either a content length
header or a transfer encoding header and
then we send our body so content length
is the easiest one looks a little bit
like this we send a response we've got
our status line there we tell what
content type it is let me tell long the
message is going to be that lets the
clients know when it can stop this thing
for new data coming down and then we
send thirty eight bytes of information
to it and if they are so so if we try to
actually do that I'll make a little
server here myself by starting up netcat
having a listen for incoming requests on
for 30 and then the browser I'm going to
ask for local host three thousand and
now you see it's spinning over here my
server just got a bunt got the HTTP 1.1
request line and then a bunch of
different headers and now my Chrome
browsers waiting for my little hand
eight server to respond so the response
format and actually have it open
this
just going to copy and paste it so we
send back a our status line which is
that it was a 200 okay and then the type
of content than the length and enter and
then one more line break to say the end
of the headers and now we can send back
37 bytes 37 bytes of content and as soon
as I send this when i hit enter the
client which is my web browser knows
it's done waiting for data and it can
display there we go and you'll see the
little spinning thing stopped um that is
the basic one way of returning responses
over HTTP 1.1 then the other way which
is something and this would work over
HTTP won't point out to this is pretty
standard the next way though which is
what sort of those added in 1.1 is
chunked transfer encoding there's
basically streaming responses back to
your client so that they can start to
make use of the information they don't
have to know in advance how long it's
going to be and they can start making
use of it as it's coming down the wire
and the response the message format for
a response that renta encoding chunked
rip message response looks like this you
tell the chunk length and then you send
it a chunk and then you tell it another
chunk length design another chunk and
you continue doing that until you've
done and then you say 0 and send it
nothing and it's like that's the end
chunk lengths are in hexadecimal and so
I'll show you
starts over again again okay bunch of
headers here um this time we will say
okay so we say HTTP 1.1 200 ok content
type is HTML and it's chunked transfer
encoding so a carriage return to
indicate end of headers and then we can
say here we go okay so this is 21
hexadecimal bytes so I have to enter hit
21 and then I give it to it and
immediately it starts displaying the
response even though it's not done and
so we can do see this this is 20 so I
say 20 I give it 20 fights for dr. 20
it's like 33 hexadecimal i kin community
continue doing this as many times as I
once and it's just going to keep waiting
until I told it that we're done and
actually I should look at good one that
actually says I'm done there we go that
is 20 to 22 that's a bit ok it's done
but it actually hasn't closed the
connection right because it's still
waiting for a zero-length chunk so I say
0 enter it's still waiting for this time
to finish three go so that is
small-batch artisanal HTTP cool so we
talked a little bit about like how we're
HT v 1.1 is and how it got there 1 point
1 is 0 like think it's 1.1 is the late
90s like 99 maybe it's on the speckles
it's amazing that we haven't actually
moved forward from it yet but that's in
the progress I've been process rather
HTTP too so first what isn't HTTP to it
is not actually a different protocol um
it doesn't change what HTTP does or how
you're like clients or browsers clients
or servers are really going to work at a
high level we still have like the verbs
you're still going to get requests and
post requests will still end URLs and
stuff like that but it is and will pass
headers along with them on request and
stuff like that but it is a different
protocol on the wire so with what is HP
not where's HP is is
a single TCP connection so now for all
your requests are supposed to go across
one tcp connection we talked earlier red
I showed that the triangle about TCP
handshake and why we want to reuse those
connections so in HTTP two we will be
able to send as many requests and its
many responses as we want across the
same connection we can have them cross
each other there's no waiting for a
response to come back every request I
believe in also response is sort of like
tagged with an ID so you just basically
send the back whenever you want and that
also means you can actually send back
your server can send your client that
response before I even asked for it
right and this in the client is up to
its updated this would be like pre
caching an image or something like that
you could actually start giving it
images before it had asked for them and
then later when your browser asked for
that image it's easy or it hasn't cash
and doesn't have to go for it so HTTP
two is very different in that it's
binaries and on the wire the on the wire
protocol is is binary instead of text
that actually means this small batch
stuff is not going to work as well so
TCP connection and the implications of a
door that we no longer would want to do
asset host chardon because actually
means we need more we have to make more
requests than necessary more connections
and concatenate in our files or spriting
our images are also unnecessary anymore
and they could technically be bad
because they make it makes it hard for
you to cash them if they're all in one
file you have to expire the cache of the
entire spreaded image set so HTTP two is
it comes out of a protocol called speedy
yet
that's yeah so there's compression is
already there compressions manatorian
http2 but the reason is it is supposed
to be more compact I'm not totally sure
now yeah they can do header compression
and how to reuse that way yeah and it
also is much easier to parse like HTTP
one has like four different ways you
could parse an incoming message pending
I'm like what it looks like speedy is
the precursor hep-2 developed by google
it's the basis for the actual hgp to
spec which is supposed to come out this
fall and not that many servers use it
but lots of big surfers use it like you
can see here you can already use it in
your browser if you have chrome it's
already using speedy which is more or
less HTTP to and you can see it in
action if you go to that URL yeah and
that's all thank you very much
so I yeah I don't think I think there
are some issues with pipelining giving
being problematic when you're traversing
like a lot the larger internet having
them sort of get out of order with each
other if you're going through like an ad
or a firewall or something like that so
I think there's some like things that
make them problematic so they're shied
away from but really it's just the fact
that they don't give they they cause
these problems with like the blocking
requests and stuff like that I think
that is part of the reasons it's just
not used I don't think so no yeah yeah